[Music]
on this Wednesday night new questions
about the RCMP response in Nova Scotia
the confusion and the chaos during the
manhunt and why did the RCMP rely on
Twitter instead of issuing an emergency
alert and why did some Americans in Nova
Scotia get warnings plus those in
mourning share their memories
she was so super good Kovach 19
outbreaks at Canadian meat and poultry
facilities how the virus is spreading
there and celebrating Earth Day during a
pandemic how the lessons were learning
now could be applied to climate change
[Music]
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we're continuing to cover the two
biggest stories in this country the
pandemic and a mass murder we begin in
Nova Scotia
the RCMP there have given more
information about their response to the
worst mass killing in Canadian history
at least 22 people were murdered
we know that for almost 14 hours
starting late Saturday night
a gunman disguised as an RCMP officer
was roaming a remote part of rural Nova
Scotia killing people he knew and
shooting others apparently at random
the RCMP now say when they arrived on
the scene they found victims but the
gunman was on the loose they began to
search yet the only alert to the public
that night was a tweet about a firearms
complaint no emergency alert was ever
issued something many say could have
saved lives by morning the RCMP began
tweeting again at 8:02 a.m. on Sunday
the RCMP began providing real-time
information on its Nova Scotia RCMP
Twitter account Twitter allowed our
information to be shared followed and
broadcast by local provincial and
national news outlets at 10:15 a.m. Nova
Scotia provincial emergency management
officials contacted the RCMP to offer
the use of the public emergency alerting
system we were in the process of
preparing an alert when the gunman was
shot and killed by the RCMP the RCMP
described the situation that night and
into the morning is fluid and dynamic
they say they know the public and the
loved ones of victims have plenty of
questions
Ross Lord has our top story tonight our
CMP investigators are still combing
through scattered devastation at 16
crime scenes with the military providing
tents and other support little has been
said officially about the victims at
this burned-out home but the location on
a remote Road in Wentworth Nova Scotia
suggests it was a targeted attack the
Mounties are short on answers to this
and other questions about the rampage
of those same questions and we'll be
seeking answers there are new clues
about the chaotic effort to stop him
investigators said today they spent the
overnight hours between Saturday and
Sunday focused on a specific area this
fire hall has bullet holes from gunfire
Sunday morning the hall was being
prepared as a shelter for residents
moved to safety from porta pick
witnesses say RCMP officers were there
but the serious incident response team
which is investigating says the gunman
was not raising questions about who
officers were firing at investigators
say the suspect did not have a firearms
license and they have not yet said what
type of guns or other weapons were used
some victims families and friends say if
the Mounties had initiated an emergency
alert instead of using Twitter messages
fewer lives would be lost but not
everyone has Twitter or even Facebook or
even Internet but we all have a
television or a telephone some people
did receive an alert the US consulate
says it used the RCMP s Twitter
information to send email alerts to
American citizens in Nova Scotia premier
Stephen McNeil says his emergency
officials reached out to the Mounties we
would not go from what's happening by
Twitter we would need the lead agency to
actually craft the message so that we
can put that out and no message was
received even though a mo had reached
out a number of times throughout the
morning to the RCMP troubling new
questions were there mistakes made by
incident commander else or someone else
or was it a matter of we need to change
procedure on how we were respond to
these types of calls when we have a gun
call maybe in rural areas our CMP
management says they were in the process
of preparing an alert when the gunman
was killed that was 13 hours after the
Mounties discovered the first victims
and identified their suspect so a lot of
the delay was based on communications
between the e mo and the various
officers and then a discussion about
what the message would would be how it
would be constructed and what it would
say
the gunmen had vehicles restored in the
garage behind his denture clinic Scott
Blakeney spruced up the shooter's
motorbikes five years ago he took this
picture in the garage which has the same
background as the notorious image RCMP
released of the mock-up police car used
during the rampage I would say the
vehicle was parked exactly where those
bikes were parked at the time I was
detailing them so when I looked acid
that's that's that's him police have
removed the clinic's storefront two sets
of gigantic teeth small consolation the
Mounties do say they're very close to
releasing a detailed timeline of the
shooters movements although they're
still piecing together some gaps
including revealing how many officers
were at these various scenes as they
tried to track down the killer Donna all
right Ross Lord in Halifax thinks the
people of Enfield Nova Scotia and nearby
communities held a memorial today to
honor the RCMP officer killed in the
line of duty a parade of vehicles made
its way to the local RCMP detachment
it's less than a kilometre down the road
from where the shooting spree came to an
end and field was the home detachment of
constable Heidi Stephenson she was a 23
year veteran of the force she was one of
many victims Global News has now
confirmed the identities of 18 of the 22
people killed they include a beloved
teacher health care workers and a
retired firefighter who rushed into
action to help his neighbor's loving
couples and a family of three also had
their lives cut short our Mike Joe Leigh
has been learning more about each of
their stories from their friends and
loved ones the TUC all of her family had
thought the darkness had finally passed
them by both of aaron tucks parents
recently died and he his wife Jolene and
daughter Emily had once again found
laughter
videos of the family are all that's kept
Jolene sister Tammy going I'm not ready
to go back to Emily's because she was
taken so early but did your voices you
know like I'm just scared I'm just going
to hold on to memories Emily is the
youngest victim in this tragedy a 17
year old girl who liked fixing engines
and had recently found her calling to be
an apprentice welder
she couldn't a person where at least she
was so super super dancer they were as
tight a family as you could imagine
separated by three time zones yet
connected through technology but in
death a mother needs more and then my
mom last night one thing that she said
she wants to hold her hand
one last time Tammy is struggling to
make that happen and as we learn more
about the victims it seems like so many
of them would have offered to help men
like retired Navy veteran and
firefighter Tom Bagley who died running
towards one of the houses set on fire
turning away his friends say simply
wasn't in his character we've heard that
a lot these Nova Scotians who died so
tragically were good the Blair's Greg
and Jamie were known for their laughter
and warmth if you're at their home you
stayed for dinner and you can believe
Greg's 46th birthday this week would
have been a blast even during times of
physical distancing partied drank it
would have been a good day it would have
been we're gonna celebrate still which
that's what he'd want so many sad
stories about happy people the least we
can do is celebrate them for who they
were might relate Global News there were
so many lives lost you can find their
stories on our website global news dot
CA / global national now to the crisis
inside long-term care homes the Premier
of Quebec has asked for 1,000 more
military personnel to help in long-term
care homes in Quebec where hundreds
people have died from Kovac 19 France
while ago says they've not been able to
find enough trained workers to meet the
immediate needs because so many regular
staff have tested positive and are
unable to work and Ontario's premier is
now also asking for the military to help
this includes resources from public
health agency of Canada and Canadian
Forces personnel we will begin by
directing that the additional personnel
will be deployed to five priority homes
in the province their support will
provide staffing relief so staff can
focus on the care of the residents
another 93 people are known to have died
of Kovan 19 in Quebec and another 37 in
Ontario the majority of those deaths
happened in long-term care homes where
there are hundreds of outbreaks now many
are getting worse including at the
orchard Villa retirement residence and
Pickering Ontario 31 residents have died
there a huge jump from four people who
died last week there are at least 145
confirmed cases of Gulf kovat 19 at that
retirement home in residents and staff
everyone who lives and works there has
now been tested for the virus the
biggest outbreaks are in long-term care
homes in Ontario is now planning for all
residents and staff in all of them to be
tested it's hoped that will give public
health officials an idea of how
pervasive the virus is in the provinces
nursing homes other facilities where
outbreaks are now coming to later meat
processing and poultry processing plants
and oil sands camps staff work in close
quarters sometimes travel to and from
work together and often share living
space well so many of us have been told
to stay home employees in those places
are still working and as Heather Eurex
West reports some say their companies
are giving mixed messages about how to
protect themselves jocelyn Ruiz has
kovat 19 the high river mother is one of
more than 500 cases connected with an
outbreak at the Cargill meat processing
plant itself of Calgary I was like am I
gonna die how about my family my
children my I was so scared
every
soon or every household that I've known
Filipino there is somebody vested
positive health officials believe the
outbreaks spread from workers to family
members and other household contacts
including some who worked at health
facilities Cargill shut down its
facility on Monday by then one of its
workers had already died we feel very
strongly that there are grounds for a
criminal investigation based on
negligence causing infection and in this
case one fatality dozens of cases have
also been confirmed at Canada's largest
meatpacking facility near Brooks Alberta
jbs says it's enhanced safety protocols
for workers but there are no plans yet
to shut the plant down this industry
watcher says closing jbs may be
inevitable but having it happen while
Cargill is down will have a significant
impact on the country's food supply
because both of them combined together
would represent roughly about 70 percent
of all the beef that is processed in
Canada for Canadians health officials
are learning the virus isn't just
spreading inside these facilities but
that how workers get to and from these
plants is a problem too it's very very
difficult to implement physical
distancing measures when everyone isn't
a bus everyone is on a bus that everyone
is bussed to work or everyone is
carpooling and and there are some
immigrant workers living together as
well the Alberta government says it may
launch a fatality inquiry into the
Cargill workers death but people in High
River now fear others may be at risk as
this outbreak spreads Heather your ex
west global news Calgary a financial
lifeline is coming for post-secondary
students and recent graduates nine
million dollars has been earmarked by
the federal government for the Canada
emergencies student benefit it will
provide up to twelve hundred and fifty
dollars a month from May to August
people who have a dependent or a
disability will be eligible for up to
seventeen hundred and fifty dollars a
month there's also a promise to create
76,000 jobs for young people including
in sectors that need an extra hand
fighting kovaydin
the prime minister also said today
support is coming in the days ahead for
seniors whose retirement savings have
taken a hit because of the drop in the
stock market there is evidence now
Americans were dying of kovat 19 weeks
before the first deaths were announced
publicly and that it was spreading
through the community autopsy results
from two people who died at a home in
California confirmed they were infected
with the virus they died in Santa Clara
County On February 6 and 17th
they had no known travel histories to
China or anywhere else that would have
exposed them to the virus suggesting
they got it through communities spread
it wasn't until February 29th that the
first kovat 19 death was officially
recorded the first confirmed case in the
u.s. was January 21st in a seattle man
who had recently returned from china a
sign of the times coming up to the new
way Parliament is meeting during the
pandemic democracy doesn't stop during a
crisis and members of parliament have
had to adapt how they work a limited
number of MPs will hold an in person
sitting once a week on Wednesdays and
for the first time in Canadian history
there will be virtual meetings of
Parliament on Tuesdays and Thursdays the
Clerk of the House of Commons says
technology isn't where it needs to be
for all 338 MPs to take part virtually
and in the UK MPs have had to adapt to
our Europe bureau chief crystal go man
singh explains how the British
Parliament has evolved how it does
business
a familiar call-out in uncharted
territory the pandemic forcing the UK
House of Commons to embrace a radical
shift the chamber limited to 50 with an
additional 120 MPs participating
virtually the member for Cardiff West
with his supplementary question Kevin
Brennan there were a few kinks I don't
know if I caught any more of that than
you did altering the course after 700
years comes with challenges it is
temporary that is part of the point of
this this is whilst this crisis lasts
Canadian politicians agree to meet
weekly in person with two additional
virtual gatherings totally unprecedented
position David Smith has spent his life
studying and writing about parliamentary
procedure he says people must be able to
see and hear politicians pitch and
defend their positions especially now
now why could she limit when the
pandemic sprung of course nothing is
happening without technology eyebrows
were raised when the UK announced it was
using the zoom which has had instances
of uninvited attendees disrupting
meetings public meeting this is
something that's usually broadcast
around the world it could be on YouTube
on Facebook so the concerns are there
but they're not significant security
accessibility user knowledge most a
great digital democracy is not perfect
but like everything right now the
priority is health crystal the Manson
Global News London
Hunger pandemic ahead a warning the
coronavirus could lead to widespread
famine
you are watching global national
[Music]
an overcrowded refugee camp in Lebanon
is under lockdown after a woman there
tested positive for Kovac 19 it's the
first case in the camp which is home to
more than 2,000 people
the woman has been moved to a hospital
and about 150 people at the camp are
being tested nearly 1 million refugees
in Lebanon are registered with the UN
and many of them live in overcrowded
camps the United Nations Food agency is
sounding the alarm about hunger it says
the impact of the pandemic could cause
multiple famines of biblical proportions
the worst case estimate is that more
than 30 million people could die in a
matter of months and 250 million could
be pushed to the brink of starvation by
the end of 2020 if immediate action
isn't taken lockdowns because of kovat
19 have made food access extremely
difficult in dozens of countries that
were already struggling with conflict
and the effects of climate change
marking the 50th earth day next we
unearth the pandemics effect on our
planet it's been 50 years since the
first Earth Day was proclaimed and look
where we are economies around the world
shut down because of a virus and the
only winner could be the environment
five decades ago an estimated 20 million
Americans took to the streets for Earth
Day there were calls to limit pollution
clean up garbage and do more to protect
the earth fifty years later it is
measures aimed at protecting people that
are also protecting the planet as Eric
Sorenson explains in the history of
environmental awareness there's never
been an Earth Day that has come closer
to reflecting the intended dream a day
of cleaner air and simpler pursuits
roads not choked with traffic the air
not filled with as much noise in Paris
tourists once took the haze for granted
now they can't be there to see the
surreal postcard that is today's Eiffel
Tower in China the Great Wall its
magnificence now under clearer skies but
it has all come from a terrible scourge
Chinese who wore masks for smog now wear
them for the virus kovat 19 has exacted
a devastating human and economic toll
but on a day set out to consider the
future
the earth the UN secretary-general says
recovery and investment should be clean
and green
we must act decisively to protect our
planet from both the corona virus and
the existential threat of climate
disruption the pandemic shows that when
humans change behavior on mass it makes
a difference satellite pictures show the
dramatic reduction in pollution in China
this year with half a billion people
under lockdown a similar reduction in
pollution in the industrial belt of
northern Italy the World Economic Forum
says overall there has been an increase
in air quality around the world but
clearing the skies temporarily won't
solve the climate crisis experts say
climate is a longer term and greater
threat than the virus the impact on
economy and human wellbeing is going to
be much higher than this coffee crisis
has ever ever had a new campaign builds
on the theme that our house the earth is
on fire and we are ignoring it some say
the change is brought on by the virus
should help us reimagine the future
change then it's been a tremendous
wasted opportunity Milan Italy hit hard
by kovat 19 sees its future in the
clearing skies planning to transform
major streets to reduce cars and
increase bikes and pedestrians a small
step in the search for something good to
come out of the pandemic Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto and that is global
national for this Wednesday I'm Donna
Friesen we leave you tonight with a look
up at the skies the Lyrid meteor shower
is peaking on this Earth Day stargazers
around Canada are sharing their images
of the dazzling show tonight's a new
moon and if you have clear skies where
you are you could spot up to 20 meteors
an hour thanks for watching take care of
yourselves bye-bye
you